This is amazing to be here.
I can't believe this is my job.
This is what I do for a living.
Sometimes I think about other jobs I could do for a living
beside this one.
My current favorite, is I wanna run one of those gay
conversion therapy camps.
It's an amazing job, guys, what do you even do?
You just take money from terrible parents and provide
a safe place for their kids to bang all summer, you know?
(laughter)
You guys havin' a good time?
Knock it out.
(applause)
Don't tell anyone what happened here,
we'll see you next summer.
Alright, you guys are a fun crowd.
I like that.
I feel like everything is so politically divided now,
you know, so it's nice to have a fun crowd.
Like, we managed to get into a controversy over the
national anthem somehow.
Everyone asking, who's standing for the anthem?
Who's kneeling for the anthem?
No one asking the bigger question,
why the countries even have national anthems?
Why, why is every country like a teenage couple?
Like, this is our song.
(laughter)
We like it 'cause it's about us.
Like, countries don't need theme songs, guys.
Especially gonna be uptight about 'em.
Stand up, shut up, take your hat off.
Our song is on.
(laughter)
Relax, you don't even like the song, you know.
Like, you like it 'cause it's your anthem,
but you don't like the song.
When was the last time you put the national anthem
on a mix tape?
(laughter)
No one's bumpin' it from their car, stop it.
And of course you don't like it 'cause you never get
to update it.
Once you pick a national anthem, it's yours forever.
We're stuck with the Star Spangled Banner.
We've got an entire studio audience.
Anyone ever use the word spangled before?
(laughter)
Time for a new song, I'm over this one.
All countries--
There we go guys.
(laughter)
And all countries play their anthems at the worst times.
Like the Olympics when you beat every country in the world
at a sport and then you're just bragging.
(laughter)
Oh, guess we're the fastest runners.
Hey, DJ, hit that anthem.
(laughter)
Everybody stand up, shut up, take your hat off.
Our song is on.
We play it before sporting events in this country,
I don't know why we do that.
Someone told me to remind us that we're all American,
which is a nice sentiment, but we don't need a song
to remind us we're American, right?
We're already at the game with 40 thousand other people
who could afford tickets, getting drunk,
eating fried food, watching mostly people of color
work on a field, you know.
(laughter)
What could be more historically American than that?
(applause)
I know we yell at them, boo.
And we take it even further than the national anthem here,
we have the Pledge of Allegiance.
Every day we just make school children profess their
loyalty to the country.
How thirsty are we?
How insecure.
You wouldn't accept that of your spouse,
if they wanted to do wedding vows every morning.
(laughter)
No, you psychopath, I told you that I love, stop it.
And these are kindergartners, six years old.
I pwedge awegence to the fwag.
What is the allegiance of a six year old even worth?
We're under attack from North Korea,
get your flat jacket on Skyler, front lines.
What do you mean you want your mommy?
You took a pledge.
Get out there.
Kids have bigger problems to deal with, man,
like bullying in schools.
That's a big problem.
A lot of people are on board to end it,
more than you might think.
Like I was at a bookstore that was having a book signing
for an anti-bullying book.
There was like 120 people in line to get their
anti-bullying book signed.
So I just cut to the front of the line, you know.
(laughter)
What are you pussies gonna do about it?
I just signed a copy myself and flipped the table
and walked off.
(laughter)
It made me think about how terrible children's stories
have always been.
Like, everyone knows the Ugly Duckling, right?
What a terrible story that is for kids.
We can't just teach 'em, be nice to ugly people,
'cause it's the right thing to do.
Instead we had to concoct a story where the moral is
be nice to ugly people 'cause they might be
attractive one day.
(laughter)
You could be making fun of a future attractive person
right now.
That's no way to live your life.
This is a tough time for kids growing up, man.
Everyone's accusing everyone of being racist.
Like racism is new.
Like it's not just baked into the cake of this country,
so much so that we don't even notice it anymore, you know.
Like zoos, we're way too okay with racism at zoos,
'cause every panda bear at every zoo in this country
is named something like Bing Bing the panda.
Ding Bing, some super racist Asian name.
That isn't even a real Asian name.
It's like something the bully in Mississippi calls the
one Chinese kid,
like shut up, Ping Ding, nobody asked you.
(laughter)
Why are we naming pandas that?
They don't know that they're from China.
They're bears.
And just 'cause they are, you don't have to name them that.
I worked with three Chinese people.
Their names were George, Jenny, and Ed.
What are we doing?
It's so American to do that.
No way is there a zoo somewhere in China where they
have American grizzly bears,
and they're like, ladies and gentlemen,
welcome Derek and Steve.
(laughter)
This has been amazing.
Thank you guys so much.
(applause)